Speaker 1: All right.
We're going to do a deep dive now into what
is happening psychologically epistemological
and cognitively with your average Trump voter
right now.
Now, let me set this up for you.
We're going to look at a couple of focus groups,
groups, folk I we might even call them.
Okay.
That PBS did with voters.
And if I came to you and I said, folks, I'm
going to pull back the curtain and show you
the insanity of the voters who want a flat
tax, you would probably look at me and say,
David, that's not super interesting, like
wanting a flat tax, even if I disagree with
it, it's not really indicative of something
wacky and zany that's going on.
And I would agree with you.
But we have a situation right now where we
have a twice indicted, twice impeached, globally
humiliated, failed former president with significant
evidence of criminality against him, innocent
until proven guilty, of course, running a
campaign that is absolute lunacy.
And yet there are still presumably tens of
millions of people that support the guy.
We're going to try to figure out what's going
on.
That's the introduction.
Let's jump into the video and then we'll discuss
how.
Speaker 3: Many of you know that Donald Trump
was indicted last week.
Raise your hand.
Speaker 1: Everybody raises their hands, although
some sort of reluctantly.
Speaker 3: How many of you have heard that
Donald Trump was indicted for a second time
recently?
Speaker 1: And the reason for hearing the
questions twice is there's two focus groups
here and they're switching between the two.
Speaker 3: Everybody knows, okay, from the
16 Republican voters we gathered yesterday
evening, there were strong reactions to the
second indictment of former President Donald
Trump.
I think he's been set up.
Oh, yeah.
Tell me why this is.
It's just too arranged.
Everything is just too arranged.
And when the FBI went in and raided his property
at Mar a Lago, how do we know what they did
and what they did it to right and wrong or
just totally.
Speaker 4: Messed.
Speaker 3: Up?
We had asked pollster Sarah Longwell, who
also publishes the center right website, the
bulwark to assemble two panels of GOP voters
in the studio of Iowa PBS.
I observe from the control room, she asked
how they're thinking about politics, policy
and current events.
At this moment, the candidates are already
descending upon their state ahead of next
year's caucuses.
And as the news of the second Trump indictment
had been breaking, it's baloney.
I think.
I mean, just why isn't Biden indicted just
because he gave them back at an appropriate
time?
I mean, really, he did exactly the same.
Speaker 4: Thing where you have a current
president who is sitting all of the DOJ on
a potential candidate.
That's never happened.
Right?
Speaker 3: Right.
They really feel like the country is going
in the wrong direction afterwards.
Longwell, who has conducted hundreds of.
Speaker 1: Okay, so let's pause there.
So asked their thought they all had heard
of the indictment.
Asked about their thoughts on the indictment,
they said it's clearly a setup.
The photos appear to have been staged, sort
of like we don't know what the FBI did, meaning
they staged or set it up in some way.
It's baloney.
Biden did the same thing and should be arrested
or charged himself.
Biden sicked the DOJ on Trump, for which there
is quite literally no evidence whatsoever.
No evidence whatsoever.
Speaker 3: Let's continue support for Donald
Trump.
How many of you distrust the FBI?
Speaker 4: The three letter agencies, the
DOJ, the CIA, the FBI?
I think when they come into the country, who
has formulated the best of intent was to put
some of these organizations or governing bodies
in place.
But how they're being manipulated now and
they're being weaponized is a bigger concern.
Speaker 1: This is just straight up what what
MAGA has been feeding these folks?
These folks have uncritically accepted these
bogus talking points.
Speaker 4: I'm kind of frustrated by it because
on one side, you know, it seems like we're
all going all out on President Trump.
And on the other side, the wheels of justice
are going very slow.
It doesn't seem to be like equal amount of
resources being devoted to looking into Hunter
Biden's laptop.
Speaker 1: And so Hunter Biden's laptop is
an issue for these folks in thinking about
what's going on right now in the Republican
Party.
Speaker 4: About Hillary Clinton and.
Speaker 3: Whatever access to.
Speaker 4: This stuff.
And she was never indicted.
You've got the.
Speaker 3: DOJ, you've.
Speaker 4: Got the FBI reporting up to Biden.
Ultimately, this goes up to Biden.
So why wouldn't you want to take out your
your toughest political opponent?
And this is election interference like we've
never seen before.
Speaker 1: That is a Trump quote.
I mean, that's that's just that's what Trump
posts to Truth Central.
This is election interference like we've never
seen before.
That's where they get this stuff.
Speaker 4: And it's disguised as Trump's a
bad guy.
Speaker 3: How many of you wanted Hillary
Clinton to be indicted for her?
Okay.
Did you think.
Speaker 1: Okay, so of the people at the table,
two of the eight did not raise their hand
that they wanted Hillary indicted.
Speaker 3: She should go to jail for what
she did?
Yes, because Trump did.
Speaker 1: Now, that's interesting.
They're saying Hillary should have gone to
jail.
Hillary was.
These are the folks who claim to be about
law and order and bemoan lack of due process
when it comes to Trump.
They're saying Hillary should have gone to
jail.
They don't know about the evidence.
They seem not to care that Hillary was cleared.
They seem not to know that there was no chargeable
crime that Hillary was involved in.
But while staying out of one side of their
mouth, we're for law and order and due process
and the justice system working properly.
They're saying imprison Hillary Clinton despite
the fact that she was cleared of criminality.
Speaker 3: I'm said that she should go to
jail for mishandling classified information.
Do you think he should be held to the same
standard that he was setting for Hillary Clinton,
or do you think that it's different for some
reason?
I think he said that when you understand his
personality and how he how he works thinks
he said that in jest.
Speaker 1: So that's this is that's a great
moment.
Okay.
This is what we call cognitive dissonance
or magical thinking, depending on your perspective.
They're asked, you know, Trump said Hillary
should also be locked up for those things.
But now Trump did it.
What about we simply hold Trump to the standard
he said should be applied to Hillary Clinton?
And they go, Well, when Trump said Hillary
should be locked up, he was kidding.
But these folks just said Hillary should be
locked up.
Were they also kidding 30 seconds earlier?
It doesn't matter.
They're in a world of their own.
Speaker 3: He didn't.
I think he's just trying to paint a weird
picture.
But should she have gotten some sort of punishment?
Yes.
Yes, I think so.
Speaker 4: He's entitled to declassify whatever
he wants to declassify.
So in other presidents that have left.
Speaker 3: Office have had classified documents.
Speaker 1: Again, another talking point straight
from the right.
Trump is entitled to declassify things, Trump
admits in audio recordings.
He didn't declassify those things.
The actions for which Trump has been indicted
took place after he was president.
When we talk about Obama or Bush and their
documents, they arranged with NARA to temporarily
store documents in specific places, disclosing
where that was on a temporary basis until
they could be permanently located either at
presidential libraries or other places.
It's not true that this guy is saying, but
it is in lockstep with what Trump and Mark
Levin and these other right wing figures have
fed to them.
Speaker 4: They were not treated the same
way as Donald Trump is being treated.
It is a two tiered justice system in this
country.
Speaker 1: Literally another word, another
phrase from Trump.
This is what this guy has fallen for.
All of it for sure.
Speaker 4: There's no doubt about it.
Speaker 3: The biggest thing is that.
Speaker 1: All right, let's skip ahead a little
bit here to other moments from from the panels.
If you're interested in the interview between
Judy Woodruff and the the pollster Sarah Longwell,
you can you can check this out.
Speaker 4: I was showing the Capitol Police
walking these people through the Capitol talking
no problems whatsoever.
Speaker 1: This is another right wing argument
which they have been fed and have uncritically
accepted.
If what the rioters did was so wrong, why
did the Capitol Police welcome them?
And of course, once you realize, well, what
was going on was once police realized they've
been unable, they are unable to keep a crowd
back, then you have to give way.
And at that point, what you want to do is
keep people calm.
But the idea was the Capitol Police thought
it was great.
They just welcomed the protesters.
How can you charge them?
Speaker 4: And then they turn around and say
they they attacked us.
Right.
In essence, the video show a whole different
story than what they're saying happened.
Speaker 1: Arguably, once we got the videos
from the January six committee, what happened
is even worse than what was originally reported.
But this guy wants to say it really wasn't
a big deal.
Speaker 3: I personally don't think that like
he was calling people to like, do like I watched
like what he said and everything.
And like, I mean, he didn't say anything to
me.
Like in watching it, that was like, you know,
Oh, yeah, he's telling them to go and like,
storming the Capitol.
You know, like, I didn't I personally didn't
feel like that that what he was said was so
inflammatory that he was just trying to, like,
you know, tear the country apart.
Speaker 4: You know, arresting people.
Speaker 1: He quite literally was trying to
overturn the results of an election he lost.
If that's not an action to tear our country
apart, I don't know what is four.
Speaker 4: Years since it happened in this
country.
I can't believe that he loves this country,
want to cause people to fight like that.
And he is against wars, which is not the typical
politician.
Speaker 2: And his words aren't.
What we call polished.
And he just blurted out.
Speaker 3: Do people want to vote for a Republican
candidate who is committed to pardoning the
people for January 6th?
Absolutely.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: That's interesting.
They want that.
They actively want a candidate who will pardon
who will pardon the rioters.
They are so convinced of the innocence of
those individuals.
Speaker 3: Guilty of these charges.
He goes through the courts and they find him
guilty.
Raise your hand if it makes you support him
more.
Speaker 1: Okay.
The question is, if Trump is found guilty,
do you support him more?
Remember due process.
We're now not talking about the Justice Department.
We're talking about a jury.
Just like this group of people is scary.
Is that is finding Trump guilty?
One, two, three, four, five, six of the eight
people say I would support Trump more if he
were found guilty by a jury of his peers.
Speaker 3: Raise your hand if it makes you
support him less.
No one and President Trump retain some measure
of support, even among those who think he
likely committed a crime.
Speaker 4: I read the indictment and it's
plain as day that he broke the law knowingly.
Whether the DOJ came after him, which I think
is very plausible and why they're ignoring
Hunter Biden's laptop, I think is a separate
issue.
But it is clear he broke the law and I think
it's time for him to go away.
And I appreciated it for what he did for the
country during his four years.
But I think that he is part of the problem.
Speaker 3: But when asked if he'd vote for
Trump if he were the nominee running against
President Biden, Trump's the nominee versus
Biden, what would you do?
Speaker 4: I would vote for him for a third
time.
I think that it's that significant.
Speaker 3: So given that and the fact that
there are protests.
Speaker 1: I think you get the picture we
are dealing here.
This is why at the top of this segment, I
said if I told you guys, I've got a group
of people that wants a flat tax, check out
how insane this is.
We would all say that's a very specific policy
disagreement that doesn't raise the sorts
of moral and ethical cult type questions that
these focus groups raise.
What this means for the Democratic Party and
the left from a strategy perspective, there's
a whole bunch of stuff culturally, sociologically,
anthropologically, that is going to take decades
to unwind from this sort of cultish ness.
I'm not dealing with that right now.
What this means from a political strategy
standpoint, as I've said before, is that it
is not worth the time to try to convince these
folks of anything.
The right way to invest time and resources
for Democrats that want to win is to work
on just getting the vote out from those who
would otherwise stay home that are as horrified
by this stuff as we are in a country with
a 50 to 60% turnout rate.
You don't need to convince those people.
You just need to find folks and say you're
not voting.
Well, then one of these people in the focus
group is going to have a say in how the country
is run instead of you.
And if that doesn't motivate more people to
vote.
Quite frankly, I don't know what would make
sure you're.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel.
Our we had a forensic audit done of the YouTube
channel last month.
We looked for bamboo fibers, barbecue sauce,
all sorts of stuff all over YouTube subscriptions.
What we found was that last month, more than
3 million people watched our videos and did
not subscribe.
If just 10% of those folks were to subscribe,
we would get to our 2 million subscriber goal
overnight.
Help us get there.
Hit that subscribe button.
We'll take a quick, quick break and be back
with so much more.